how do I nail the ultimate best [ __ ]
resting face I think a good and sucking
of the Chi mmm since we like maybe
notice goes strong it's just the little
surf that [ __ ] welcome back to camera
meet Josh Smith and today we are set to
slay because we have the queen of
slaying right here Jodi comer is it so
today you are gonna get your best agony
on on yeah and I have some questions
here that are inspired by killing Eve
and you're gonna help me solve these
problems I will try my best
my boyfriend's gone AWOL by I need to
prank call some contacts in his phone to
quiz them about his whereabouts okay
what persona should I adopt being the
queen of adopting a persona and do you
have any tips than nailing a cracking
cover-up accent busy from this this
fella Russia tense P is mom tell him he
needs to get home where are you going
you to use ready
classic black plastic chicken nuggets on
the table babes
when you're trying to get into a persona
yeah what's the go-to place how do you
really nail there it depends sometimes
before I'm doing villanelle I have to
like roll my arse in Dad's I find it
quite easy to slip in an old lady yeah I
couldn't ever stay in character I'd
struggle to take myself too seriously
my boss is playing some serious mind
games mm-hmm how can I outmaneuver him
and come out as the top dog quit
seriously I used to have a part-time job
and and the woman mmm hated me I mean I
just I hate the job is over what was
that job
on the checkout them for me I think it
was probably because I was hungover I
had like I had this Saturday tensile for
shift oh that's the killer one yeah a
tensile for as well so
oh maybe don't quit maybe just a sip I
say do you do you leave her to me or him
I have been on the shower for quite some
time shell the shelf
and I want to become a temptress but my
look is a more from Peter and seductive
it's not meanness I'm sorry you're like
I'm not on the show honey whatever you
feel comfortable in yeah I didn't
believe in dress I feel like whatever
you dress for anyone else that's when
you go I'm walk on just a pink fluffy
dress and you're good to go right My
partner is up to no good
eyebrow and I thank you next and I need
to get my best spying game on spying
game what are your top spying tips
oh I mean they go to Instagram is in
there
yeah little Instagram store I was gonna
say never hurt nobody but it really I'm
looking to put the sass into assassin
love this I love it when you said this
to me that time and I was like oh my god
it's going in my Instagram bio I'll give
you the copyright okay yeah okay how can
I get myself a sass over over I think
this is a question for Ariana I feel
like she's a queen of know when you're
on the tube and like you've got a song
again and you look around and you're
like no one else is on your on your
wavelength wait that's like yeah almost
like you're in your own music video yeah
are used to not merely a superstar all
the time
[Music]
Shantanu that's it I'm gearing up for a
faceoff with my rival okay
she's been a [ __ ] she's back stop being
the center well
vile girl what should my game plan of be
when she walks past a little foot out
tripper over bit my piece I'm sorry I'm
thinking a villanelle I'm a big believer
in walking away yes like Ray David
walking away yeah yeah yeah yeah like
Craig give a crate David always yeah so
basically the ultimate vices channel
your inner Arianna you're cray David and
you're Jamil your superstar my crew you
cook whatever and then finally here's a
nice positive one to end our series for
tripping people up over here I'm lacking
some serious confidence oh I really we
need to take these people on a night owl
oh my god JD let's get this out I need
to give myself a cracking pep talk in
the mirror what p.m. a mantra do you
recommend if I'm really nervous about
something and late
I'm like you can do with Judy yeah just
classic classic all about the classics
you guys smash it you're gonna do it
it's gonna be great
yeah like look at yourself in the eyes
in the mirror yeah unnaturally give
yourself a PMA yeah ma I always think as
well like I'm going in like thinking
about auditions and stuff because you're
the person who has like go back in the
room if you've been told no six billion
times
it's only you kind of gets you back in
there with a positive attitude so I
think yeah you've got to be a bigger
support yes got be your biggest ally
amen amen honey well hon I'm feeling
more confident
I hope these poor people at home can
hear his side problems hopefully being a
bit more competent I love to get this to
keep the spammers babe yes me me Oh
everyone's invites everyone's invited me
at the end as well you can't not go out
without sushi is that we're going to
miss the shimmy when you walk across
that's my signature Jodi claimed were
coming brucey me
[Music]